le directeur de ce supermarché comment
se répartissent les ventes actuellement
depuis le début de la grève
eh bien disons que se répartissent
surtout dans l'alimentation ou en faire
nous vendons des farines le des sucres
des civils en priorité sur les autres
sachez mesdames est-ce que la grève vous
a beaucoup gênés oui madame pourquoi on
dépasse cas il faut se provisionner puis
on a pas les moyens
et vous madame nous ces questions de la
paye pas ce qu'on a l'habitude d'être
d'être payé 25 et des chèques sont
fermés mon mari est maçon et toucher
toujours juste pour manger pour payet
autre que les comptes chèques sont
fermés et puis on a été pris de court
est-ce que la grave vous a posé beaucoup
de problèmes au moins énormément parce
que je suis venu du pas de calais pour
la communion j'ai saisi à faire là bas
coûts mari et pour vous éviter de
repartir tous les partis on est ici
depuis vendredi passé c'est là que vous
avez pu gêner bien sur qu'il faudrait
qu'ils touchent pas les pays je voudrais
pas à manger il faut se préparer aux
enfants jusqu'à présent ça va à peu près
un coup les grèves nous ont beaucoup
gênés dans votre vie de m'embrasser ou
parce que mariette l'hôpital
alors je peux pas lui faire du feu n'ont
en revanche avitaillement ça fait des
provisions
un petit peu quoi parce qu'il y avait
plus grand chose quand on voit que pour
les gosses quoi avoir siphonné
qu'est-ce que vous avez pris surtout
issus non non pas de nom enfin très peu
ce que je ne crois pas une grève va
durer éternellement tout va et main très
peu qu'est-ce que vous avez pris surtout
le sucre je trouve ça tout à fait idiot
du fait que nous vivons quand même eu
lieu nous vivons pas en période de
guerre et je pense que c'est ça c'est
complètement idiot de se ruer sur les
étalages comme certaines ménagères ont
fait d'ailleurs au détriment des petites
bourses
on voudrait pas fait de stocker pas même
politique aux banques il avoir une boîte
qu'est ce que vous montrez au zaïre on
les pommes de terre
et puis les tomates
est ce que vous avez fait des provisions
au nom parce que de toute façon on ne
savait même à progresser alors on n'a
pas vu faire des provisions
bahia des achats qu'on n'a pas pu faire
parce que pouvez vous retirer d'argent
ou vos enfants
est ce que vous avez eu des problèmes
pour le garder oh oui sauf que les
garçons personnellement non enfin
pour mes enfants oui vous avez écouté ce
matin la radio non avec qui on aimerait
beaucoup d'apprendre que pensez-vous des
accords de ce matin j'ai proposé cette
passion l'a pas entendu parler des
protocoles d'accord sur les salaires
je vais écouter les radios non non non
c'est pas si mauvais robin je suis tout
à fait satisfaite parce que les ouvriers
ont obtenu satisfaction pour la majorité
je pensais surtout pour les petits
revenus encore une fois on a été déçus
pouvoir se passer la fête des mères
rae s'est passé dans le calme disons
dans le calme surtout au point de vue
chiffre d'affaires mais pas eu d'achats
d'enfants seront à l'honneur
non non la vie justement fait les
enfants cette année manqué ils n'avaient
pas leurs petites cartes les économies
pour faire l'achat pour le moment